THE BLACK MARKET:
$400 to a $1000. This is how much you can make
per article by writing about banks, presidents,
and other notable figures on Wikipedia.
That’s why teachers told us not to trust what we
see on Wikipedia. After all, anyone can change
it. But, have you actually ever seen someone edit
or change a Wikipedia article. I know I haven’t.
But somehow, there’s a Wikipedia article about
virtually any topic that you can think whether
that be President Calvin Coolidge's pet raccoon or
fluid mechanics. In fact, according to a Wikipedia
page, there’s a total of 58 million Wikipedia
pages. Traditionally, these articles are written
by super dedicated volunteers. People who strongly
believe in the free sharing of information like
this guy. This guy, Steven Pruitt, has apparently
made nearly 3 million edits on Wikipedia and
written 35,000 original articles all for no
compensation. He says that the idea of making
it all free fascinates him, but not all Wikipedia
writers are quite as noble. Here’s the thing,
the influence of Wikipedia has grown tremendously
over the past 20 years. Nowadays, the information
found on Wikipedia is often taken as gospel
because oftentimes you don’t even know that it’s
from Wikipedia. Take voice assistants for example.
Whether your asking Alexa, Google, or Siri, much
of the information you’re consuming is directly
from Wikipedia. The same thing is true for ChatGPT
as well which has been trained using the entirety
of Wikipedia. In fact, companies use Wikipedia so
much that Wikipedia’s parent organization,
Wikimedia, has actually started charging
companies for using Wikipedia, and their first
customer was none other than Google themselves.
This in itself has raised concerns about how
these big tech companies can exercise control
over Wikipedia, but more importantly, this has
added an indescribable amount of credibility to
Wikipedia. All of a sudden, writing for Wikipedia
isn’t just a case of contributing to some online
forum. It’s a case of defining the truth as what
you write will be repeated by billions of voice
assistants and generative AIs around the world. I
think you can see why this would be an extremely
valuable resource to push a certain narrative.
Welcome to the black market of Wikipedia.
PUBLISHING AN ARTICLE:
Writing
Wikipedia articles to push a certain narrative can
be super lucrative, but getting into the business
isn’t all that easy. According to teachers,
publishing articles is something that just about
any random joe can do but that’s completely false.
In fact, the process of publishing to Wikipedia
is extremely hard and long, especially for new
accounts which is where probably you’ll have to
start. It turns out that Wikipedia is one of the
only services that we all use on a regular basis
but don’t have an account for. Anyway, once you
create a new account, you’ll be greeted by this
page which is basically a dashboard to track
your social credit on Wikipedia. As you can see,
I have none but this is where you’ll have to start
if you wanna get into publishing actual articles.
Wikipedia will suggest a bunch of articles for
you to make small edits to in terms of spelling,
grammar, and tone. You’ll have to edit atleast 10
pages before you unlock publishing functionality
but if you don’t wanna seem sus, you likely
want to make hundreds if not thousands of
edits before writing full on articles. Once you
build up this Wikipedia credit congratulations,
you can finally start writing your very own
articles and publish them into the ether. Wait,
nevermind, it’s not that easy. Even after
you build up social credit on Wikipedia,
you can’t just publish articles. Or I guess you
can but it doesn’t actually get published when
you press publish. Instead, it gets added to a
massive cue of over 4000 articles waiting to be
published. It usually takes about 6 months to get
through this cue after which your article will go
through a rather arduous verification process.
The number one factor that Wikipedia is looking
for when approving articles is notability. No
amount of fancy writing or editing will get you
around this requirement. In fact, Wikipedia
deletes and rejects over 200 articles every
single day because they lack notability. How do
they determine notability? Well, it comes down
to how many independent articles already exist
regarding the subject. Corporate press releases
and websites do not count as notability for
obvious reasons. Wikipedia is looking for atleast
3 high quality sources that contain substantial
discussion about the topic. A simple mention is
not sufficient. They’re also scanning for any
sort of evident bias or narrative that you’re
trying to push. These rules are already pretty
stringent if you’re writing about an organization
or event. But if you decide to write about a
person, the scrutiny increases several fold.
The reason being that Wikipedia wants to avoid
libel and slander which was notoriously common
back in the early days. In fact, at one point
in time, Wikipedia claimed that Tony Blair,
the former prime minister of the UK, worshiped
Mr. small moustache. Nowadays, this wouldn’t fly
because each and every line about a living person
has to have a direct reference. If it doesn’t,
it gets removed even if its accurate. And all of
that is just scratching the surface of Wikipedia’s
verification process but if you’re able to get
through the gauntlet, well now you’re in business.
PAID ARTICLES:
Unlike the process of publishing an article,
finding people who are willing to pay for an
article isn’t that hard. For obvious reasons,
companies and people of interest are incentivized
to write articles about themselves to increase
their notoriety. But, this is something that most
people and organizations avoid doing themselves
because of the repercussions. Writing articles
about yourself is strictly prohibited as that’s
a clear conflict of interest. If Wikipedia’s
reviewers sense that a given article was written
by an affiliate, not only is the article taken
down but the topic is flagged making it even
harder for future articles to be published
about the topic. This is why many companies
turn to a professional albeit shady service that
specializes in this art. Such businesses have a
team of Wikipedia editors with a bunch of social
credit to push articles that clients want. One
such business is Wikipedia Thrive. Their pitch
on the main page is literally “Hire Certified
Wikipedia Consultants and Claim the Fame”. There
are certain parts of the page that almost make the
page seem legit. For example, they claim that
they do exhaustive research and utilize domain
experts to get authentic information. But, just
below that you run into statements like this. Our
certified Wiki experts have complete command on
the exhaustive wiki guidelines, so they can get
approval on the first run. Now, why exactly would
a legitimate article be worried about getting
approval? Obviously no reason at all. The reality
is that the entire site is designed to convince
customers about why Wikipedia pages are so
important, even more important than Google and why
clients should invest in creating a page that will
surely get approved. From an outside perspective,
this is obviously super sketchy but the thing to
keep in mind is that the people who are looking
for this service are indeed looking for something
sketchy so it works out perfectly. I mean,
according to their stats, it looks like business
is booming. Wikipedia Thrive apparently has 15,000
edits, 6000 live profiles, and 50,000 satisfied
clients. Even if we assume that each client was
only charged a $100, we’re talking about $5
million in revenue. But, that’s honestly low
balling it. Way back in 2015, a freelance writer
named Mike Wood claimed that clients pay him
$400 to a $1000 per article. So, 8 years later,
that rate has likely only gone up. Even at $400,
we’re talking about $20 million in revenue. At a
$1000, we’re talking about as much as $50 million
in revenue and that’s just this one business.
There’s dozens just like them. This one company
called WikiExpertsInc for example is apparently
ranked as the #1 Wikipedians company. They claim
to have published 4900 articles for 3400 clients
over the past 10 years and their motto is “Your
Global Fame Is Just One Call Away!” Some
other businesses include wiki counsellor,
wikinative, wikiconsultancy, wikiconsultant,
americanwikieditors, and Lumino just to
name a few. Some are more sketchy than others but
none are as sketchy as a true white glove service.
BENDING REALITY:
Most of the businesses we’ve covered so far
are definitely sketchy but they're not full
on propaganda machines. They’ll simply cherry
pick sources that support a given narrative
and write articles using these sources. But,
some more white glove services will just go
ahead and create the sources themselves which
brings us into the world of paid media. Getting
paid media itself is not that hard. There are
legitimate ways to make sponsored posts and/or
get press releases featured on sites like Forbes
and CNBC. But, the problem with these avenues is
that Wikipedia doesn’t accept sponsored posts or
press releases as valid sources. So, ironically,
getting a Wikipedia page is actually harder than
being featured in mainstream media. To get into
Wikipedia, not only do you have to be featured
on such websites in a substantial manner but you
have to be featured in a seemingly natural and
independent manner. This is where PR agencies
like Spynn come into play. The way this works is
pretty simple. These companies basically have a
bunch of connections with writers who work
at these outlets and they pay them a fee to
cover certain topics. Spynn has connections with
the following outlets. Theoretically speaking,
the writers are the one who control what ends up
getting published but this really just comes down
the ethics of the given writer. There’s obviously
gonna be writers who are willing to post anything
for the right price. At Spynn for example you can
get you one story on Yahoo Finance or Business
Insider for a $1000. They’re so confident in
their abilities that they even offer a money
back guarantee. For $3000 a month, they can get
you into 6 publications within 3 months, so it’s
really $9000 in total. And finally, for $5000
a month, they can get you into 12 publications
within 3 months, so for $15,000 in total. Let’s
just say that this business is also booming as
Spynn has been able to generate $30 million worth
of revenue within just 2 years of launching. It
looks like there’s a lot of egomaniacs out there
desperate for publicity and attention. Anyway, if
you’re looking to get into Wikipedia from nothing,
you probably wanna opt for the enterprise package,
so we’re talking about 15 grand. After that,
you’ll also have to pay for a thousand or so for
the Wikipedia article itself. So, we’re talking
about a total of 16 grand. That’s the price to
get into Wikipedia without any prior notoriety.
But, just because you get your wiki article posted
doesn’t mean that you’re safe. Once an article
is posted, Wikipedia will continue to monitor
the interest on your page and other writers will
be able to suggest changes to the page. If your
page doesn’t get much interest and no one suggests
any changes, that in itself will be a red flag.
After all, what type of person who’s featured in
12 publications within a matter of 3 months gets
only 7 views on their Wikipedia page. No man
at all. Wikipedia bots are constantly on the
look out for such pages. In fact, they take
down 1000 such pages on a daily basis. So,
if you wanna keep your Wikipedia page up, you’ll
have to start paying for bots to view your page.
But, that’s simply the price you have to pay if
you’re trying to buy your way to fame as that’s
the black market of Wikipedia. Someone else that’s
devoted to the free sharing of information is
the founders of the Pirate Bay. If you wanna hear
about their legendary story, check out this video.